hey crazies in our last video about
light we talked a little bit about
fusion and I said this every four
protons comes together to make one
helium nucleus but four protons have
more mass than one helium nucleus then
people started asking questions in the
comments and I was like why don't we
just make a video about it so let's do
it first when we say fusion we
specifically mean nuclear fusion as in
the nucleus of an atom originally the
word nucleus meant the curdle at the
center of a nut but we've since made it
mean the center of anything small big
things have a core small things have a
nucleus
it's that suit yeah but what's fusion
alright I guess I kind of skipped that
didn't I fusion means to combine
multiple things into one thing with
nuclear fusion smaller atomic nuclei
combine to form larger ones usually this
happens in the core of a star but it had
happened a little in the early universe
it can also happen in hydrogen bombs and
fusion reactors basically anywhere with
similar conditions to the core of a star
so what kind of stuff can we make that
depends on what you're combining the Sun
is fusing hydrogen into helium which
shouldn't be that surprising since the
Sun is mostly hydrogen then again so is
the regular matter in the universe just
to be clear though when we say hydrogen
we don't mean a hydrogen gas molecule or
a hydrogen atom we mean hydrogen nucleus
it's so hot inside the Sun the hydrogen
can't hold on to its electrons anymore
I'm free it's just a bunch of electrons
and protons zipping around freely we
call this a plasma oh lick the stuff in
my blood
no that's biology this is physics
totally different things
anyway those protons are still called
ionized hydrogen or H+ which as you can
imagine leads to all sorts of confusion
just keep in mind for the rest of the
video whenever I refer to something on
the periodic table I only mean its
nucleus okay so why doesn't fusion just
happen everywhere oh good question you
can slap neutral atoms together all day
but atomic nuclei are charged and
similar charges don't like to be near
each other whether you're talking Jung
it uranium middle east iron or little
tiny hydrogen all nuclei carry a
positive charge which
will repel other positive charges it's
called the Coulomb barrier and you need
a really strong force to overcome it
like oh I don't know maybe gravity the
Sun is a lot of that despair I mean it
does contain ninety-nine point eight
percent of the solar system's mass a lot
of mass means a lot of gravity so the
cylinder a giant cloud of mostly protons
uses its own gravity to force those
protons together Hulk smash
doesn't helium have neutrons in it
though I was wondering how long it was
gonna take you to ask about that
so yeah confession time while the idea
of nuclear fusion is simple the actual
processes are not which is pretty
typical of real life now that I think
about it anyway before we get into the
details there are some things you should
know first
during all nuclear reactions energy
momentum and charge are all conserved
rest mass is not conserved but it is a
type of energy so it's a counter core
that way we'll call it rest energy for
the remainder of the video
second neutrons can decay into protons
whenever they want
because neutrons have more rest energy
than protons it doesn't happen a lot
otherwise there wouldn't be any neutrons
but it does happen
third protons can decay into neutrons
but only with a little help
that extra rest energy has to come from
somewhere usually the kinetic energy
lost during the collision with another
particle and finally fourth remember
that protons don't like to be together
but neutrons can help keep them together
near the top of the periodic table the
number of each is pretty even
but as you move down the table you need
more neutrons than protons all right now
we're ready for some nuclear reactions
we said before hydrogen fusion turns
four protons into one helium and some
light but some of that light comes from
Anti Matter annihilations with electrons
there are also a couple of neutrinos
that get made cuz why not and this whole
process can happen a couple of different
ways the proton-proton chain adds
protons one at a time creating neutrons
along the way through decay and
releasing light and neutrinos that zip
out of the Sun the CNO cycle releases
all the same light and neutrinos but
uses carbon nitrogen and oxygen along
the way to build helium either way the
Sun will eventually run low on hydrogen
forcing it to fuse helium into carbon
which
do using the triple alpha process in
case you're wondering sometimes helium
nuclei are called
alpha particles and it takes three of
them to make one carbon
hence triple alpha even after you get
the temperature right a lot of other
stuff still has to go a certain way if
you smash two protons together and
neither one of them decays into a
neutron then they just fall back apart
if you smash two helium's together
the third one better get there soon or
the first tube will just fall back apart
if you want to make even bigger nuclei
it just gets even more difficult the
bigger a nucleus is the more it wants to
repel other nuclei sometimes you can get
the core of the star hot enough for that
but other times you have to sneak in a
neutron and wait for it to decay into a
proton
it's called Neutron capture and it can
happen either slowly or rapidly the
point is making all the elements on the
periodic table is harder than it sounds
but if we figure it out we've got a
great source of clean energy so are you
excited about the future of fusion power
let us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be crazy
in the last video we learned how to
properly calculate orders of magnitude
permit response time liam de lo sauces
was wondering exactly how Enrico Fermi
made his original estimate for the blast
power of that nuke well we don't know
exactly a Fermi estimate is sometimes
called a back-of-the-envelope ested
because it's like something you would
jot down on the back of a used envelope
unfortunately Fermi was so good at this
never actually wrote it down some people
have tried to guess what he did links in
the dooblydoo SML strength said he
learned more about logs in four minutes
than he did in two semesters at school
school I'm glad I was able to help and
that's awesome I also agree that school
kind of sucks a lot of the time at least
in the US but I think that's just
encouragement to try to make school
better so it's more like the current
model of school
Andy Kirkham nice one with the resistor
color bands I totally approve for those
of you looking for other Fermi estimates
elliott gray suggested one from the xkcd
what-if series if you haven't noticed
the book is on my shelf linked in the
doobly-doo thank you so much for all the
encouragement we've got a great lineup
of videos planned for the next few
months oh that reminds me every December
I usually do a three video series
because I haven't returned but I want to
switch gears this year there are a few
topics I haven't covered because they
require more than five minutes and you
can't really divide it up so rather than
a series I'd like to make a longer video
instead just something to look forward
to see you next time